let's go next to alex from baltimore
alex go
hey james can you hear me i can although
it's something's up with the connection
but let's see if we can struggle through
it
okay how about now is that better that's
dramatically better
okay i just turned okay and i also
wanted to mention that i am in a quiet
room inside so we shouldn't have any uh
loud uh annoyances outside have you
treated the walls with acoustic foam
um i don't know if they did or not okay
i might have anywhere okay so i want to
get you to analyze my take on medicare
for all on a state level with the
stories coming out of california
i get i also i live in maryland the last
governor's race the democrat was very
progressive ran on medicare for a single
payer in the state of maryland okay and
i was a little hesitant on it because
on the state level the funding mechanism
is
a a better question to ask because you
know they can't just print money and
balanced budgets actually matter yep and
maryland is such a small geographical
state like i think you can be outside
this state within 30 miles no matter
where you live and i think it's more of
a reasonable argument to say all the
all the people with means that you're
going to try to get funding for can just
move to pennsylvania virginia delaware
um so i was a little hesitant to go with
it on the state level is that a decent
take do you think or am i missing
something i'm not sure i understand what
you're saying you're saying is it a
problem for state level medicare for all
that people can move into the state from
elsewhere
people know that um
because you have to raise funds for
state yeah um for medicare for all yeah
and a lot of people aren't a lot of
people who aren't gonna be happy with
having higher taxes even if it's cheaper
in the long run okay and and in maryland
you could
move across the border to pennsylvania
and not have to pay those taxes so you
would lose a funding mechanism
well but if you require people to be
residents to have the the to participate
in the program then don't you solve that
issue
i suppose but my i guess my thought was
if you have uh less if you have a
an influx of people moving out to avoid
it then it's harder to raise funds for
it yeah but i think that that problem i
don't think that's really a big thing
because if a state sets up state
medicare for all they say okay here's
the way it works
in order to be to to have this
single-payer system cover you you've got
to be a resident that's it you've got to
be a resident so if people from another
state that doesn't have the system come
in they can still be seen at hospitals
but they have to bring insurance that
they have just like they do now do you
see what i'm saying
yeah i guess i see what you're saying so
you can solve that that's a solvable
problem
all right fair enough and um i know
you're at the end
quick question what is your
favorite adult beverage
my favorite adult beverage
uh i don't know i'm partial to sort of
like uh wheat and white beers
uh craft beer guy yeah yeah well you
should definitely if you're ever in
baltimore we have lots of good craft
beers you can you can check out not ipas
i hope right
they run the game and there are a bunch
of ipas but there's lots of other stuff
too i don't want any ipas anywhere near
me that's my only thing uh i actually
agree with you there are some that i
think are okay but no i'm more of a
blogger i actually like dark beers now
more than i used to but anyways all
right thanks for taking my call all
right thank you for the call and what a
beautiful note on which we can end today
i'm always
devastated that i can't get to everyone
who calls in
but we will take calls again and i hope
to hear from you next time we'll take a
quick break and be right back